comme dans chaque caserne
la journée commence tout au 126e
régiment d'infanterie de brive la
gaillarde
ils ont vingt ans ils sont jumeaux l'un
s'appelle jean claude il est mécanicien
dans le civil et grenadiers voltigeurs
dans l'armée jean pierre a le même
métier que son frère ait la même
spécialité
durant son service militaire pour eux
comme pour les 1000 appelé du régiment
la vie de la caserne en 1975 est guère
différente de celle qu'a connu leur père
sac à dos casque lourd fusil marche
corvée ti et parcours du combattant
jean claude et jean pierre non pas une
réputation de meneur ou de
contestataires ils sont nés à trélissac
en dordogne dans une famille de
cultivateurs et pour eux le service
militaire fait partie des choses
normales de la vie leur grand-père était
fantassins en 14 leur père artilleurs en
40e sont bidasses pour un an à brive la
gaillarde le malaise de l'armée ne les
concerne pas ils ne réclament ni le smic
ni biais de chemin de fer gratuit pour
partir en perm
ils ne se plaignent pas de la condition
militaire mais comme la plupart des 300
milles appelés du contingent
ils sont sceptiques sur le rôle du
soldat de base dans l'armée française en
cas de conflit ont fait ce n'est pas
parce que sur la méthode à où on est
entraînés baume 6 juillet une guerre
avec tout le matériel que possède
l'armée
je vois pas nous diriger hp [ __ ]
dedans quoi je veux maintenant
crapahuter sur le terrain c'est zéro
vous pensez que vous perdez votre temps
personnellement l'homme le service
militaire il faut le faire comme dit mon
frère c'est un peu l'homme
pour d'autres ce qui sont plus âgés que
nous par exemple pour eux oui parce que
mettons que des gars qui songent pas mon
professeur de chiens comme ça pour moi
c'est aussi ici
s'ils font des études de droit
on gagne convient maintenant enfin si à
partir du 1er janvier 2008 115 francs
par mois ont été augmentés on s'en sort
avec ce prix là année où il n ya plus
rien et les perdent aussi le père ont en
assez souvent
qu'est ce que vous attendiez du service
national
moi je voyais tout à fait différemment
je l'imaginé comme plus sévères beaucoup
plus de discipline discipline au plus
strict quoi même s'ils jouent à la
guerre avec des balles à blanc
le grenadier voltigeur de brive la
gaillarde ne prend pas son rôle de
soldat tellement au sérieux
dans la zone interdite de mailly-le-camp
près de châlons sur marne
d'autres appelés font leur service
militaire au 3e régiment d'artillerie
pluton la première unité de l'armée de
terre après la marine et l'aviation a
disposé de l'armement atomique
il faut donner de plus grandes
responsabilités aux appelés a déclaré le
ministre de la défense afin de les
intéresser à ce qu'on leur apprend
durant leur service militaire
ceux de mailly-le-camp sont intégrés à
la dissuasion nucléaire
il participe aux alertes mais si un jour
l'ordre de tir était donné la plaie du
contingent ne se transformerait pas en
pourvoyeur de désastre s'est engagé à
bord de la mx 30 qui déclencherait le
tir atomique
le cerveau du pluton est plus un
technicien qu'un soldat ici l'homme du
contingent n'apprend pas à tirer au
fusil ou à lancer des grenades
il pilote un amx 10 d'escort ou
transportent le coeur de la fusée pluton
les bienvenus
passé le couvert conducteur
l'artilleur nucléaire et moins morose
que le grenadier voltigeur car il a
l'impression qu'il serait plus utile
dans l'armée française en cas de conflit
un tracker si on évoque des questions de
soldes ou de transport gratuit pour les
permissions
le malaise est ici le même qu'ailleurs
mais en ce qui concerne l'instruction
militaire
je peux vous assurer qu'elle est
parfaitement comprises il faut bien voir
que nous appeler ne sont exclues
d'aucune mission d' aucune tâche
d'aucune responsabilité nucléaire ils
ont parfaitement conscience que la bombe
atomique
c'était aussi et qu'elle implique une
rigueur dans le service qu'il faut
supporter même quand on est un appelés
du contingent est ce que vous
l'impression d'être intégrés directement
la défense ah oui absolument
nous participons sans nous pour ainsi
dire l'affiché ne pourraient pas partir
pas vu que c'est nous qui la monte haut
sur le char n'avais pas l'impression de
perdre votre temps
c'est incontestable le moral de
l'artilleur nucléaire dans l'armée
française est meilleur que celui du
grenadier voltigeur devant ces tireurs
de l'apocalypse bidasses à des complexes
il a tort l'atome ne le remplacera sans
doute jamais complètement sur les champs
de bataille